Buonasera, dunque questo incontro di stasera sarà forse un pochino più impegnativo di
quello di ieri e me ne scuso, nel senso che ieri abbiamo gettato alcuni parametri complessivi
per orientarci in un fenomeno complicato come quello delle crociate e poi abbiamo anche
cercato di raccontare, che del resto è il mandato che mi è stato dato, raccontare le
crociate, e domani racconteremo di nuovo molto. Oggi quello che cercherò di fare è, lo sapete
già, un pochino più complesso forse, perché si tratta di analizzare due aspetti paralleli,
anzi che si rispecchiano uno nell'altro, del fenomeno crociato, e cioè la nascita dell'idea
di guerra santa nella cultura cristiana, e la nascita e poi soprattutto l'evoluzione
del concetto di jihad nella cultura islamica. Come capite il rischio di mettermi nei guai,
sono cose abbastanza delicate, e quindi mi scuserete se faccio una premessa, e la premessa
è questa, mi capiterà di usare e di fare riferimenti ai testi sacri delle grandi religioni,
naturalmente. Farò dei riferimenti all'Antico Testamento, pochissimi forse al Nuovo, e farò
dei riferimenti al Corano. Questi sono testi che i credenti naturalmente ritengono siano
la parola di Dio, la parola del Signore, come si dice nella liturgia cattolica, cose dettate
da Dio agli uomini attraverso i profeti. Io naturalmente toccherò questi testi prescindendo
dal fatto se ci si debba o meno credere come parola del Signore. Tra l'altro le opinioni
divergono nel senso che l'Antico Testamento, come forse sapete, è considerato parola del
Signore da tutte le grandi religioni. L'Antico Testamento è considerato voce di Dio che parla
ai profeti, dagli ebrei, dai cristiani e anche dai musulmani, dal momento che il Corano
è largamente radicato nell'Antico Testamento. Il Nuovo Testamento è considerato parola di Dio
solo dai cristiani, ma non dagli ebrei e neanche dai musulmani. Il Corano è considerato
parola di Dio dai musulmani, ma non dagli ebrei e neanche dai cristiani. Ora, io qui tratterò
questi testi da storico, ovviamente. Ognuno in cuor suo può sapere se crede o meno che
quella sia la parola di un Dio creatore, ma penso che possiamo essere tutti d'accordo
sul fatto che l'Antico Testamento, il Nuovo, il Corano, sono stati messi per iscritto in un
certo momento storico da uomini che se li sentivano dettare nella testa e che li hanno
scritti con le parole della loro lingua e della loro epoca. E credo anche che possiamo
essere tutti d'accordo che questi testi poi hanno continuato, nei secoli e nei millenni,
a influenzare il modo di pensare e il modo di agire dei fedeli delle grandi religioni
monoteiste. Non però sempre allo stesso modo. Ecco, se dovessi riassumere in una sola
frase, quello che stasera cercherò di far vedere, è che l'insieme dei precetti o degli
esempi contenuti nei testi sacri di una religione, a seconda dei momenti storici, ha potuto essere
interpretato in modo molto diverso, preso alla lettera, oppure invece interpretato in
modo allegorico, letto e riletto e ripetuto con molta insistenza o invece messo da parte
quasi dimenticato. Ecco, questa è una dimensione storica delle grandi religioni e del loro rapporto
con i testi sacri, che secondo me è molto importante che abbiamo presente. Bene, mi scuserete
per questa noiosa premessa. Veniamo al dunque. Parliamo di cristiani e guerra santa. Il punto
di partenza è che i primi cristiani rifiutavano assolutamente l'idea che si potesse fare la
guerra, che si potesse fare il soldato come mestiere, che si potesse dunque fare un mestiere
che inevitabilmente prima o poi ti obbliga a uccidere. Per i primi cristiani, e parlo
dei cristiani dei primi secoli, dei secoli delle persecuzioni e delle catacombe, il rifiuto
del servizio militare era un punto d'onore, un punto fermo della loro fede, ed è uno dei
motivi tra l'altro per cui erano perseguitati. Le grandi persecuzioni che colpiscono a più
riprese i cristiani nel mondo imperiale romano, e poi più in generale la diffidenza del governo
imperiale verso questa gente, che si percepisce sempre anche con gli imperatori che noi poi
magari ammiriamo di più, Traiano, Marco Aurelio, ma che quando si tratta di cristiani invece
hanno un atteggiamento appunto di diffidenza e di disprezzo preconcetto sorprendente. Questo
è dovuto in gran parte proprio all'effetto sovversivo di questo rifiuto del servizio
militare. A dirla tutta apriamo piccolissima parentesi, c'era anche un altro motivo, sono
due in fondo. L'altro motivo è che nell'impero si dava molta enfasi alla divinità dell'imperatore
e alla necessità che tutti i buoni cittadini riconoscessero l'imperatore come una divinità
facendo dei sacrifici per l'imperatore. Questo era, come dire, un minimo comune denominatore,
uno a casa sua poteva adorare gli dei che voleva, ma in quanto cittadino dell'impero
doveva fare il sacrificio all'imperatore in pubblico. I cristiani e gli ebrei, ma gli ebrei
sono un caso particolare, un piccolo popolo che non fa proseliti, che se ne sta nel suo
paese o nelle sue piccole comunità comunque, gli ebrei e i cristiani rifiutano questa cosa
e mentre con gli ebrei bene o male si arriva dei compromessi, i cristiani che crescono,
si diffondono in comunità sempre più ampie, fanno proseliti, ecco spaventano molto.
Il motivo forse principale, a dire il vero, delle persecuzioni più dure, lo si vede
negli atti delle persecuzioni, negli atti dei processi, è proprio questo. Si vedono
i procuratori che hanno il cristiano davanti e gli dicono ma fallo questo sacrificio,
io non posso. Ma cosa ti costa? È un gesto, è un gesto da buon cittadino, tu puoi credere
quello che vuoi, fallo, non posso, guarda che ti devo mettere a morte, non posso, fallo,
no. E i procuratori condannano a morte. Ma l'altro motivo, fatta molto lunga ma chiudiamo,
è che i cristiani fermamente rifiutano il servizio militare e questo nell'impero romano
è un atteggiamento solversivo, perché l'impero romano è basato sulla guerra e soprattutto
nel tardo impero, Diocleziano per esempio, uno dei grandi persecutori dei cristiani, Diocleziano
è anche quello che rimette in piedi un servizio militare obbligatorio, come quasi non c'era
più prima, che impone delle leggi severissime per cui i figli dei soldati devono fare il soldato,
perché questo modo di bloccare, di cementificare la società, ognuno fa il mestiere del padre
è percepito come l'unico modo per arginare il crollo, la dissoluzione dell'impero. Allora
in quell'impero pieno di gente che per obbligo legale deve fare il soldato, si diffonde questa
religione che invece dice no, tu il soldato non lo puoi fare. E si diffondono fra i soldati
queste idee e ci sono i soldati e gli ufficiali che si dimettono. E però non possono dimettersi
troppo comodo e vanno al martirio. Molti dei cosiddetti santi militari che fanno parte
del panteo dei santi cristiani, San Sebastiano, tanti altri, sono militari che sono stati
martirizzati perché hanno voluto lasciare il servizio militare. Poi il paradosso se vogliamo
è che in altre epoche spesso sono diventati patroni di reggimenti o cose del genere, in quanto
santi militari appunto rappresentati con le armi, ma loro sono andati alla morte e sono diventati
santi perché pensavano che la loro religione gli proibisse di fare il soldato. Bene, questo
atteggiamento estremistico però cambia da un giorno all'altro nel momento in cui cestano
le persecuzioni e l'impero romano riconosce la religione cristiana. Lo sapete tutti e con
Costantino all'inizio del IV secolo. Nel momento in cui l'imperatore dichiara ufficialmente che
i cristiani sono buoni sudditi come gli altri, sono liberi di praticare la loro fede come vogliono,
e tutto sommato ben presto si comincia anche a capire che sono anche un po' più uguali
degli altri perché l'imperatore li apprezza e li favorisce e l'imperatore stesso è vicino
alle loro posizioni e dopo Costantino tutti gli imperatori saranno cristiani tranne uno,
Giuliano, che non per niente i cristiani hanno chiamato Giuliano l'apostata, cioè quello
che ha rinnegato la fede. In questo impero che da Costantino in poi è ufficialmente cristiano,
di colpo i cristiani cambiano atteggiamento. Esistono atti di concili che dicono no, ora
che l'imperatore è cristiano noi non possiamo rifiutarci di aiutarlo quando ha bisogno. Quindi
se l'imperatore ha bisogno di soldati noi dobbiamo darglieli, non è più sbagliato per
un cristiano fare il soldato per l'imperatore cristiano. È possibile fare la guerra? Sì. Comincia
un dibattito che durerà a lungo, di cui accenneremo alcune tappe, ma non c'è nessuna
esaltazione della guerra, ma si comincia a ragionare sul fatto che però se comandata da
un sovrano legittimo e quindi cristiano, la guerra i cristiani la possono fare. Dai testi di questi
secoli, di questi primi secoli, noi capiamo che il problema è grosso e non è facilmente
risolto. Noi capiamo che i cristiani si interrogano e le loro coscienze sono incerte. C'è un
testo straordinario di Sant'Agostino su questo. Inizio quinto secolo, siamo ormai cent'anni
dopo Costantino, dovrebbe essere un problema risolto. L'impero è ufficialmente cristiano,
tutti sono cristiani, l'esercito è pieno di soldati cristiani, eppure ancora a quell'epoca
a Costantino arriva una lettera di un ufficiale dell'esercito imperiale romano che gli dice
ma guarda che io non sono tranquillo, io mi sto tormentando perché non capisco se questo
mio mestiere è compatibile col fatto che sono un cristiano. E Agostino dà una risposta
contraddittoria, cioè dà una risposta in cui noi vediamo il suo ragionamento come se
parlasse, a volte lo facciamo, di parlare a voce alta per chiarirci le idee. Lui scrive
e dice, comincia così, non si può pensare che piaccia a Dio chi presta servizio militare
e porta le armi. La prima cosa che gli viene in mente è ancora quella, talmente è forte
l'idea che c'è il comandamento non uccidere e quindi le armi non si possono portare. Però
Agostino immediatamente si rende conto che questa è una bella teorizzazione ma il mondo
va da un'altra parte. E per fortuna, diciamo così, in realtà i testi sacri della sua religione
gli offrono anche degli elementi per ridiscutere il problema. Infatti come continua subito dopo
seconda frase di questa lettera di Agostino? Ma anche Davide portava le armi, il re Davide.
Vedete che viene fuori subito l'Antico Testamento. Nel Nuovo avrebbe fatto più fatica, è vero
che Gesù a un certo punto dice, non sono venuto a portare la pace ma la spada. Però
su cosa veramente abbia voluto dire non si è smesso di discutere. Nell'Antico Testamento
è molto più facile, i re degli ebrei fanno la guerra e massacrano i nemici ed è Dio
che gli ha detto di farlo. Anche Davide portava le armi e moltissimi altri uomini giusti di
quel tempo. Dopodiché Agostino va avanti a ragionare su questo tema e finisce con una
soluzione che è il meno peggio che abbiamo trovato noi uomini finora perché ancora oggi
credo che sia il meno peggio che si può dire. In certi casi è necessario, si fa la guerra
per raggiungere la pace.
Va detto che Agostino, mi fermo un attimo su di lui perché è uno insomma dei fondatori
del pensiero cristiano, Agostino ha continuato anche in seguito a riflettere, a interrogarsi,
a grovigliarsi su questa cosa e nelle opere della vecchiaia viene fuori composizioni più
nette. Sembra quasi che a un certo punto si sia stufato di queste eterne discussioni.
C'è un'opera in cui dice, ma cosa c'è da biasimare nella guerra? L'uccidere uomini
che un giorno dovranno morire? Questo è un biasimo non degno di uomini religiosi. Dove
si vede che Agostino, che era pur sempre un intellettuale antico, tende ancora a sovrapporre
l'idea del filosofo, che non si deve far influenzare da certe considerazioni, a quella
dell'ecclesiastico, del teologo. E poi prosegue appunto e mette più chiaramente
appunto il pensiero che già abbiamo accennato prima. Cito, talvolta è necessario che i buoni
facciano la guerra contro i violenti, per comando di Dio e del governo legittimo, costretti
dalla situazione, al fine di mantenere l'ordine. Dunque, fare la guerra può essere legittimo.
Siamo, ben inteso, ben lontani dal dire che è una bella cosa. Siamo supposizioni che dicono
sì, ci addolora, ci tormenta, ci aggroviglia, però non possiamo non riconoscere che a questo
mondo può essere necessario farla. Il che non vuol dire che si possa allegramente uccidere
in guerra, perché c'è questa contraddizione molto curiosa. A me, che studio queste cose
da tanto tempo, riesce tuttora difficile capire in pratica come facessero. In sostanza, per
tutto l'Alto Medioevo, quindi fino all'anno 1000, fino alla prima crociata quasi, la Chiesa
cristiana dice che la guerra è legittima se è richiesta da un sovrano legittimo, però
uccidere in guerra è comunque peccato e richiede la confessione e la penitenza. Ora, tenete
presente che nel primo millennio il cristianesimo dà alla confessione e alla penitenza un carattere
molto diverso da quello che ha assunto poi più tardi. All'epoca la confessione, per esempio,
era pubblica. Non c'era il confessionale in cui, in segreto, io confesso i miei peccati
al sacerdote. La confessione era pubblica, si faceva davanti alla comunità e c'era una
forte insistenza sul fatto che quando hai peccato, per essere riaccolto nella comunità
dei fedeli, devi fare una penitenza anch'essa pubblica. Penitenza che può essere un periodo
di digiuno e cose di questo genere. La cultura cristiana del primo millennio è tutta intessuta
di riflessioni su quali penitenze bisogna dare per quali peccati, quali sono le colpe
più gravi. Vengono scritti manuali, e noi sappiamo queste cose, per nostra fortuna, perché
loro scrivevano dei manuali. Dei manuali per i confessori che dicevano, insomma, a seconda
della colpa quale penitenza bisogna dare. E noi in questi manuali vediamo i confessori
dell'alto medioevo, dell'epoca delle invasioni barbariche, poi di Carlo Magno, e poi fino
all'anno 1000, che si interrogano e non hanno tutte le stesse opinioni. C'è chi dice
sì, uccidere in guerra, e certamente è un peccato, ci sta scritto non uccidere, però
non è un peccato grave. Ecco, ci sono le attenuanti, quindi chi uccide in guerra deve
fare penitenza, naturalmente, però, ecco, tre giorni di digiuno, per esempio. Altri confessori
ritengono che la cosa sia più seria, e ci sono manuali che dicono, no, chi ha fatto,
chi ha ucciso, anche se per una giusta causa, comunque non può andare in chiesa, per esempio,
per un certo periodo, deve tenersi lontano dai riti sacri, dalla messa, dalla comunione,
per parecchio tempo. E poi ci sono anche quelli più moderni, viene da dire, che dicono, ma
no, se la guerra è legittima, allora anche uccidere in guerra non può essere peccato,
non è peccato. Quindi la chiesa, e sto parlando della chiesa occidentale, la chiesa cattolica
latina, è divisa. Fino all'anno 1000, fino all'epoca della prima crociata, ci sono episodi
in cui vengono celebrate battaglie ricordate con gratitudine perché lì si è riuscita a
non uccidere quasi nessuno. Ecco, i vincitori sono stati moderati, non hanno ammazzato i nemici
che fuggivano e poi con qualche giorno di penitenza, insomma, si è chiusa la cosa in
bellezza. Vorrei sottolineare, anche se ne so pochissimo, però, che la chiesa greca,
quella che noi chiamiamo la chiesa ortodossa, la chiesa orientale, che in questi secoli ha
rapporti sempre più allentati, sempre meno forti con la chiesa latina e con il papato,
ecco, la chiesa greca rimane invece molto più rigida. La chiesa greca continua a pensare
che uccidere in guerra, anche se può essere legittimo, però è un peccato grave e si parla
per esempio di tre anni di esclusione dalla messa e dalla comunione per chi è ucciso
in guerra. Ma quello che vorrei sottolineare per chiudere questo aspetto, siamo arrivati
ormai alla vigilia della prima crociata, al di là delle contraddizioni e del groviglio
che evidentemente rappresenta questo problema, è che comunque ufficialmente esiste un sistema
in cui uccidere in guerra, qualunque guerra, nel migliore dei casi non è un peccato grave,
però comunque si richiede che si faccia penitenza. E questo è l'aspetto che è difficile da
immaginare per noi, perché poi quella dall'altro punto di vista è una società guerriera.
Carlo Magno fa la guerra tutti gli anni contro i pagani per espandere la fede cristiana e
in qualche modo bisogna però immaginare che quando tornavano dalla guerra, chi sapeva
di essersi sporcato davvero le mani di sangue, comunque doveva fare dei riti purificatori.
Se vogliamo la possiamo risolvere pensando che in molte religioni sono richiesti riti
purificatori anche per cose che non sono colpe, che ne so, il ciclo femminile per esempio,
che però dopo chi la donna che l'ha avuto deve purificarsi prima di poter tornare ai riti
religiosi. Questo succede in vari ambiti e così si può pensare che per i nostri antenati
dell'Alto Medioevo chi è ucciso in guerra è impuro, comunque magari non è una colpa
ma è impuro, si deve fare penitenza.
Voi capite a questo punto che svolta rappresenta la prima crociata con l'atteggiamento che abbiamo
forse solo accennato ieri ma che più o meno già conoscete e comunque chiederemo meglio
adesso di quelli che partecipano alla crociata e che invece si convincono fin da subito che
non soltanto la crociata è una guerra non già legittima, poco, è una guerra santa, è una
guerra che non è soltanto permessa ma è addirittura doverosa ed è bella e secondo punto quelli
che ci vanno si convincono molto rapidamente che ammazzando i nemici in una guerra come
quella non si commette nessunissimo peccato ma anzi si fa qualche cosa che ti garantirà
il paradiso. Ecco la svolta come vedete è veramente drammatica, qui c'è davvero una
cesura nella storia del cristianesimo e dell'occidente di quelle su cui vale la pena
di fermarsi. È una svolta, questo è molto curioso, che sembra quasi imposta dal basso,
dalla mentalità collettiva perché all'inizio la chiesa quando bandisce la crociata, sì,
va molto in questa direzione però con delle cautele. Papa Urbano II quando nel 1095 comincia
a predicare e a chiedere ai cristiani di prendere le armi e marciare contro i turchi e andare a
conquistare Gerusalemme, Papa Urbano II dice, ed è già molto, sia chiaro, per tutti quelli che
partiranno, se incontreranno la morte in viaggio o in battaglia contro gli infedeli, vi sarà l'immediata
remissione dei peccati che io accordo per l'autorità che Dio mi concede. Come vedete da un lato è molto,
il Papa si sta prendendo una responsabilità molto grossa, si sta prendendo la responsabilità di
dire chi partecipa a questa impresa per il solo fatto che partecipa, se muore avrà la remissione
dei peccati. Però per chi conosca le sottigliezze dei teologi, e questa è la gente che aveva studiato
e misurava le parole, la remissione dei peccati non è ancora tutto. La remissione dei peccati
vuol dire che i peccati lei commessi è come, però io Papa con la mia autorità posso fare questa
cosa straordinaria di dirti che anche se hai ucciso e quindi commesso peccato mortale,
però non ne pagherai le conseguenze. Me l'assumo io il Papa la responsabilità di dire che di
questo sarai perdonato, il che tra parentesi non implica che poi uno non si faccia centomila
anni di purgatorio per aver ucciso. La remissione dei peccati vuol dire soltanto, ecco come quando
uno si confessa sostanzialmente. Lì il problema è, si muore in guerra, non si fa in tempo a
confessarsi. Che succede? La gente se lo pone questo problema. E il Papa dice, non preoccupatevi,
se anche fate in tempo a non confessarvi è come se l'aveste fatto. Ma non sta dicendo in
nessun modo non commettete peccato. È troppo sottile la differenza. Non so per noi. Certo
per quelli che partono per la crociata si scopre che è troppo sottile. Perché invece
l'atteggiamento di quelli che vanno, come noi possiamo giudicarlo dai cronisti che ci
parlano di loro, che ci raccontano il loro modo di comportarsi, e noi abbiamo anche qualche
testo scritto da crociati. Già per la prima crociata c'è una breve storia in latino scritta
visibilmente da un cavaliere. Era un caso raro, un cavaliere che sapeva scrivere, sapeva
il latino, qualcuno c'era però, e lui ci parla in prima persona. È un crociato vero,
di base, diciamo così, che racconta le cose come le ha viste lui. Ecco, questi qua si convincono
invece subito, che visto che stanno facendo questa cosa enorme, rispondendo a questo appello
del Papa, lasciando tutto, rischiando la vita, seguendo la via di Cristo verso la passione,
imitando gli antichi martiri, perché c'è anche questo che è molto forte nella mentalità
dei crociati. Ci sono di nuovo i martiri. Sono 700 anni che tranne rarissime occasioni
era impossibile farsi martirizzare. Giusto qualche monaco che andava a convertire i vichinghi.
Adesso invece diventa possibile per chiunque scegliere di morire da martire. Basta farsi ammazzare
dai pagani per cercare di conquistare, di liberare, come dicono loro, il santo sepolcro.
E dunque loro si convincono molto rapidamente, altro che remissione dei peccati. La base è
convinta che sta facendo una cosa meritoria e che ammazzare i pagani è una cosa meritoria,
perché sono martiri quelli che combattono. Tra il momento in cui uccidi e il momento in cui sei
ucciso, citerò poi un testo di San Bernardo che è molto chiaro su questo, c'è poca differenza
in fondo. Sono due facce della stessa medaglia, comunque di un martirio.
Questa mentalità si vede anche molto bene nei testi letterari dell'epoca. L'epoca della
prima crociata, lo sapete dai ricordi di scuola, è anche quella in cui cominciano a
nascere le prime letterature in volgare, le prime canzoni di trovatori, le prime canzoni
di gesta, la canzone di Orlando, la chanson de Roland. Ecco, lì è messa in scena nella canzone
di Orlando, la guerra contro i pagani, è tutto trasfigurato in una dimensione fiabesca,
favolosa, però ci sono alcuni punti fermi molto chiari. Noi raccontiamo le gesta dei
valorosi cristiani che hanno combattuto contro i pagani e, cito a memoria dalla chanson de
Roland, i pagani hanno torto e i cristiani hanno ragione, chiuse virgolette, è proprio
un verso della canzone, e quando i guerrieri di Orlando, la retroguardia di Carlo Magno,
si fanno massacrare dai pagani a Roncisvalle, sanno e dicono che stanno andando ad affrontare
il martirio. E affrontare il martirio vuol dire essere certi di andare in paradiso, ovviamente,
anche se si sta morendo con la spada in pugno coperta di sangue. Cito ancora dalla canzone
di Orlando. Così disse Orlando, qui subiremo il martirio, ma sarà fellone chi non si venderà
caro. Colpite, signori, con le spade lucenti. E dunque è evidente che nella mentalità dei
crociati si è realizzato un cortocircuito. Io che sto rischiando la vita e vado al martirio e
sono un martire, e come martire sono certo che andrò in paradiso, ed è chiaro che andrò in paradiso
anche se ci sono andato ammazzando infedeli. Non c'è spazio per sottigliezza a questo punto.
Se vogliamo possiamo aggiungere una piccola appendice. Una delle cose sgradevoli delle
crociate, che oggi rendono un po' difficile per noi l'empatia con la gente che ci andava,
anche se poi vediamo l'entusiasmo con cui ci andavano e finiscono per esserci simpatici
lo stesso, uno degli aspetti sgradevoli, come molti di voi sapranno, è che proprio in
occasione della prima crociata ci sono le prime esplosioni di violenza contro gli ebrei
in Occidente. Le comunità ebraiche che per molti secoli erano vissute in Occidente, più
o meno discriminate, ma non troppo a dire il vero, non c'erano ghetti, non c'erano stelle
gialle da portare sul vestito, né niente. Ecco, queste comunità ebraiche vengono aggredite
sistematicamente con distruzioni e stermini dalle folle dei crociati in movimento verso
la Terra Santa. Subito, già le prime bande di crociati che si radunano tra la Francia
del Nord e la Germania, nella Valle del Reno, appena incontrano le comunità ebraiche nelle
grandi città del Reno, a Magonza, a Spira, ecco, le aggrediscono e massacrano. Ed è una
scia ininterrotta di aggressioni e di stermini di ebrei lungo tutto il viaggio dei crociati.
Dopodiché arrivano nei Balcani e nei Balcani cominciano a incontrare gente ancora più
strana. Qui mi rifaccio al racconto di quel cavaliere anonimo a cui accennavo prima, un
rosa conto di un crociato che ha partecipato alla prima crociata dal basso, insomma, nella
massa. Questo racconta che a un certo punto nei Balcani si sono trovati di fronte a una
cittadina fortificata e gli hanno spiegato che in quella cittadina vivevano dei manichei.
E chi sono questi manichei? Che razza di bestie sono? Eh, sono gente che non crede in
Dio, anzi crede che ce ne siano due, che il mondo l'ha creato un Dio cattivo. Eretici
quindi, sì, eretici. In effetti, aperta parentesi, noi sappiamo che questa vecchia religione
manichea aveva lasciato delle tracce nei Balcani, erano rimaste comunità fin dal tempo, dal
sardo d'antichità, di manichei. Per questi che vengono dalla Francia o dall'Italia
meridionale, come molti normanni, mai sentita questa gente, ma appena gli dicono che razza
di bestie sono questi, la reazione è immediata. Andiamo e massacriamoli tutti. E infatti aggrediscono
la cittadina, la prendono da sedio e sterminano l'intera popolazione. Assolutamente convinti
di stare facendo quello per cui sono partiti, cioè sterminare i nemici di Dio. E se volete
ci ricolleghiamo così e chiudiamo questa parentesi a un cenno che ho fatto ieri, al fatto che il
papato a un certo punto comincerà a pensare che forse la crociata si può bandire anche
contro nemici diversi dai musulmani e anche con obiettivi diversi dalla conquista di Gerusalemme,
perché se i nemici di Dio ce li abbiamo anche in casa, non si vede perché non usare la
crociata contro di loro. Il papato non si sognerà mai di scatenare i crociati contro
gli ebrei, la questione è molto complessa, ma certamente il papato in quello non ha
responsabilità. Però contro gli eretici sì, come sapete quando l'eresia catara acquista
particolarmente piede nella Francia meridionale al punto che la chiesa si spaventa davvero, viene
bandita una crociata per sterminare questi catari o albigesi come venivano chiamati. Chiuso
a parentesi, quello che mi importava che fosse evidente è il profondissimo cambiamento
di mentalità che si compie e aggiungiamo anche che la chiesa di fronte a questa reazione
dell'opinione pubblica, a questo convincimento profondo delle masse, in realtà alla fine
rinuncia a cercare di frenare. L'idea che chi muore durante le crociate va direttamente
in paradiso qualunque cosa abbia fatto e che quindi ammazzare i miscredenti è comunque
una cosa buona, ti porta in paradiso, ecco questa idea alla fine non è più possibile
metterla in discussione. Tanto che a un certo punto nel regno di Gerusalemme nascono delle
comunità, siamo subito dopo la prima crociata, mi seguite, la prima crociata ha avuto successo
1099, conquistata Gerusalemme, conquistato un amplissimo territorio che comprende tutto il
Medio Oriente attuale, trasformato in un regno cristiano. I musulmani tutti intorno, assai
infuriati e decisi a riconquistare questi territori alla vera fede e ributtare a mare gli invasori.
Quindi il regno va difeso, quindi arrivano continuamente volontari dall'Europa che vengono
a menare le mani perché hanno fatto voto di stare un anno in Terra Santa e difendere
la causa. E c'è anche gente che viene e si ferma, vengono tanti militari, cavalieri, gente
che sa combattere e che decide che magari ha tanti peccati da scontare e che d'ora in poi
si dedicherà a una causa per cui può continuare a menare le mani, che è l'unica cosa che sa
fare, ma si salva l'anima, che è una cosa a cui loro tengono, perché loro ci credono
molto profondamente al fatto che c'è l'anima, c'è il paradiso, l'inferno e sono lì che
ti aspettano.
Ora, tra i cavalieri che vengono in Terra Santa per aiutare una mano, a un certo punto nasce
l'idea, fondiamo, noi diremmo fondiamo un'associazione per combattere, un'associazione di guerrieri
che combatta contro i musulmani con degli statuti, delle regole, ma loro come ragionano?
Loro vivono in una civiltà profondamente intrisa di valori religiosi, quindi a loro non viene
in mente di fondare un'associazione, forse se fossero stati quei mercanti genovesi che
li trasportavano attraverso il Mediterraneo, magari i mercanti genovesi ce l'avrebbero pensato,
ma i cavalieri francesi, sono tutti francesi all'inizio, che arrivano lì e non fondano
un'associazione, pensano di fondare un ordine religioso, ci consacriamo alla vita religiosa,
ma non come fanno i monaci a casa che stanno chiusi nel monastero tutto il tempo a pregare
e che bisogna aver studiato per farlo, noi siamo cavalieri, gente che fin dai 7-8 anni
ha imparato ad andare a cavallo e a combattere, questo sappiamo fare, però vogliamo consacrarci
a Dio, fondiamo un ordine, una comunità religiosa, prendiamo dei voti di poverità,
di castità, di ubbidienza ai nostri superiori e lo statuto di questa comunità, lo scopo
per cui essa esiste, sarà di combattere contro gli infedeli e di difendere Gerusalemme.
Fondano questa associazione, si cercano una sede, trovano il tempio, l'antico tempio di
Gerusalemme, trovano degli spazi lì e si chiamano i cavalieri del tempio, ovvero i cavalieri
templari, che tutti abbiamo sentito nominare. Quindi i templari nascono così, come una confraternita
di cavalieri, laici, per lo più analfabeti, che però vogliono essere monaci, ma monaci
di un tipo molto particolare.
Ora, come vedete da un lato già il fatto che un'idea del genere possa venire fuori
dimostra in che clima siamo. Perché i monaci, tutti i monaci che io studiando il Medioevo
ho incontrato fino a quel momento, sono gente che rifugge con estremo orrore dalla violenza,
così come dal sesso, dai piaceri fisici e così via. Sono gente convinta, tutti i monaci
che sono esistiti fino ad allora, che chiunque viva indossando l'armatura e menando le mani
finisce dritto all'inferno. Anzi, i monaci si tormentano abbastanza, perché questo vuole
anche dire che i loro padri e i loro fratelli sono tutti all'inferno, però ne sono convinti
lo stesso. Qui vedete come si è ribaltata la mentalità di molti, anche se non di tutti,
lo vedremo subito. La mentalità di molti si è ribaltata talmente che diventa possibile
pensare di fare il monaco e combattere contemporaneamente. Ma come vi dicevo, non tutti si sono già
spinti fin lì. Quando si diffonde la voce che è nata questa confraternita e che chiedono
di essere ufficialmente riconosciuti come un ordine religioso, la reazione della Chiesa
è estremamente perplessa. Ci sono molti che dicono, ma questi qua si sono bevuti il cervello,
non è nemmeno pensabile che uno possa pretendere di essere monaco. Sei cavaliere, combatti gli
infedeli, va bene, ti abbiamo detto che è una buona cosa. Però, da lì a pensare che
possiate fare i monaci, c'è una differenza enorme. Per diversi anni lo statuto dei Templari
rimane incerto e infuria una polemica. Questo è già un mondo, quello cristiano, del XII secolo
che sta diventando più complesso. Ci sono più scuole, si scrivono più libri, girano, si discute.
Si era discusso tantissimo al tempo della lotta per le investiture, papato, impero. È un mondo
in cui si discute. Si discute anche di questo. È legittima questa idea dei Templari o è una
stortura, una perversione. La cosa rimane in bilico. Finché non interviene uno dei
religiosi più famosi dell'epoca, San Bernardo, San Bernardo di Clairvaux o di
Chiaravalle, se volete dirlo in italiano, che è il leader in quel momento, non il
fondatore, ma il leader dell'ordine più agguerrito, dell'ordine monastico più
agguerrito che esiste in quel momento, i Cistercensi. I Cistercensi sono dei
Benedettini che interpretano però la regola Benedettina in senso molto
austero, molto arduo, insistendo molto sulla durezza di vita, la penitenza, il
lavoro. San Bernardo è un intellettuale noto in tutto il mondo cattolico, in tutta
l'Europa latina, celeberrimo. I suoi trattati contano. Quando lui si pronuncia
su un argomento viene ascoltato. È un uomo estremamente aggressivo che ha ottenuto
grandi privilegi per il suo ordine, che ha combattuto ferocemente certi avversari e
quello che ha cercato di far mettere in galera in tutti i modi Abelardo e i primi
filosofi di Parigi, che cominciavano a ragionare un po' troppo sulla fede
religiosa, anziché accontentarsi della mistica. Quindi, mi sto tratteggiando in
poche parole, un uomo estremamente importante, ingombrante e ascoltato al
suo tempo. San Bernardo decide di intervenire in questa controversia sui
Templari e decide che i Templari sono una buona cosa. Hanno ragione loro. Per i tempi
che stiamo vivendo, e naturalmente San Bernardo è anche uno che a un certo punto
dice, eh, anche questo nostro mondo ha le sue notti e non poche. Quindi i tempi che
stiamo vivendo sono quelli che sono, ma noi dobbiamo affrontarli. E per i tempi in cui
stiamo vivendo, questi Templari che vogliono combattere contro i nemici di Dio sono
molto meglio di tutti quei cavalieri che vediamo intorno a noi, che combattono
fra loro, combattono per saccheggiare, per arricchirsi, per opprimere i poveri.
Questi sono molto meglio. E quindi questa nuova cavalleria deve essere sostenuta, promossa.
Vogliono essere monaci? Lo siano. Garantiamogli che andranno in paradiso se combattono.
E scrive un trattato, l'elogio della nuova cavalleria, che proprio è destinato a sancire
la legittimità e la bellezza dell'ideale dei Templari.
Io vi cito qualche frase, tanto per, direi, chiudere a questo punto, sì, chiudere il discorso
sulla guerra santa cristiana, perché a questo punto è abbastanza evidente, direi, no, il
tipo di atteggiamento che si è creato con la prima crociata e che è durato poi a lungo,
anche se attraverso discussioni di tanti tipi. Però chiudiamo leggendo
San Bernardo? I cavalieri di Cristo, che sono i Templari, combattono con sicurezza le battaglie
del Signore, senza timore e senza peccato, quando uccidono il nemico. 50 anni prima non
aveva detto questo, naturalmente, Urbano II, adesso invece senza peccato. La morte data
o ricevuta, vedete che è la stessa cosa, la morte data o ricevuta per il Cristo non comporta
peccato alcuno, e merita anzi grande gloria. Il Templare accetta con bontà la morte del
nemico, a titolo di riparazione, e ben più volentieri dona a se stesso quando cade in battaglia.
Con serenità uccide, con serenità muore, e se uccide, rende un servizio al Cristo. Quando
è ucciso, si deve dire non che è morto, ma che ha raggiunto il suo scopo. Dalla morte
del pagano, il cristiano trae gloria, perché il Cristo viene glorificato. Ma quando è il
cristiano a morire, allora splende ancora più viva la generosità divina, perché il
re chiama a sé il cavaliere per donargli la ricompensa. Bene, passiamo adesso, forse più
rapidamente, perché il tempo è passato, ma meriterebbe di fermarci un po', all'altra
fase della medaglia, perché questa gente trovava pane per i suoi denti, naturalmente.
Il concetto di Jihad è un concetto che è presente in diversi brani del Corano, non senza
contraddizioni. Il Corano è un libro ricco di contraddizioni, come qualcuno forse saprà.
Ci sono addirittura dei versetti che poi risultano ufficialmente abrogati da versetti
successivi, per esempio. Ma lasciamo stare questo. In realtà poi il concetto di Jihad, se uno va
a vedere, emerge abbastanza chiaramente dalle diverse allusioni che il Corano fa a questo
tema. Jihad in realtà è soltanto una parte di un'espressione complessiva che suona qualcosa
come Jihad fisabilillah, e vuol dire combattere sulla via di Dio. Non mi fermo, perché se ne
parla spesso, ne parla spesso Franco Cardini, per esempio, qualcuno lo avrà sentito, sul
fatto che in realtà tradurre Jihad con combattere può essere discutibile. Che forse oltre a combattere
c'è un'accezione più ampia di sforzarsi, dare tutto se stessi. Non mi fermo su questo,
anche perché non sono uno specialista, e poi comunque l'accezione di combattere, che è
quella che qui ti interessa, in ogni caso emerge da diversi brani del Corano. Accennerei
soltanto una cosa. Combattere sulla via di Dio. Io proprio preparando questi incontri
sono andato a rileggere dei testi, appunto, crociati, e sono rimasto colpito vedendo, proprio
in quel famoso Cavaliere Anonimo, che ho già citato più volte, che è un testo bellissimo,
come questo crociato di base ha recepito la predicazione di Urbano II. Scrive all'inizio
della sua opera questo crociato, che cito per l'ultima volta, poi parliamo di musulmani,
che Urbano II disse ai fedeli che chi voleva salvare la sua anima non esitasse a intraprendere
con umiltà la via del Signore. Ecco, c'è qualcosa di comune alla mentalità di questa
gente che da una parte e dall'altra comunque sente fortemente questo richiamo a seguire,
a intraprendere una via, non è il cammino di Compostela del professor Di Freddi, naturalmente,
a intraprendere una via su cui i fedeli devono marciare e correre il rischio di morire,
naturalmente. Ecco, questo parallelo non l'avevo mai visto, mi ha colpito mentre preparavo
questo incontro e volevo accennarlo. Dopodiché, cosa dice il Corano sulla guerra santa, sul
jihad? Citerò diversi brani da sure diverse, sapete che il Corano è diviso in questa specie
di capitoli, chiamiamoli così, che si chiamano sure, questo è della sura XXII, che tra l'altro
si chiama la sura del pellegrinaggio, come vedete anche qui i termini continuano a incrociarsi,
dunque, 22, 40, 42. È stato dato il permesso di reagire a quelli che vengono attaccati,
poiché essi subiscono violenza, e certamente Dio li può soccorrere. Hanno il permesso di
reagire quelli che sono stati scacciati dalle loro dimore senza diritto, solo perché dicevano
il nostro Signore è Dio. Dio aiuterà certamente chi aiuterà Lui. Dio è forte e potente.
Ecco, se ci fosse soltanto questo, faticheremmo molto, credo, a riconoscere il jihad come noi
lo abbiamo presente, ma i commentatori sono d'accordo che questo è uno dei brani in cui
il concetto è chiaramente quello. In altre parole, cosa viene fuori? Che il jihad è legittimo
e antiprescritto, in questo caso specifico, in altri casi vedremo che si allarga, sia
chiaro, ma in questo caso specifico si dice che è legittimo per difendersi, quando si è
aggrediti. Capite, forse, come mai per secoli gli arabi non avessero più avuto granché bisogno
di occuparsi di jihad. Dopo le grandi conquiste arabe del VII-VIII secolo, il mondo islamico
era molto più avanzato e progredito dell'Occidente cattolico, naturalmente, e sostanzialmente
non erano minacciati da nessuno. Ma appena i primi crociati mettono piede in terra musulmana,
immediatamente in tutto il mondo islamico, come un'ondata, la notizia corre e evoca questo
tipo di atteggiamento. Il fatto che nel libro Dio ha detto, chi è aggredito deve difendersi
e Dio lo aiuterà. Ma in realtà c'è un brano, in un'altra sura, la seconda, in cui il jihad
è teorizzato in modo nettamente più ampio, perché qui il problema diventa cosa fare con
chi non riconosce il vero Dio. E qui ci sono i brani, devo dire anche il singolo versetto
più inquietante in assoluto che si è contenuto nel Corano su questo, e come sempre succede
poi delle correzioni, degli aggiustamenti, degli elementi di moderazione.
Combattete nella via di Dio contro coloro che vi faranno la guerra, però non eccedete,
poiché Dio non ama quelli che cedono. Uccideteli quindi, ovunque li troviate, e scacciateli
da dove essi vi avranno scacciati. Mi scuserete se insisto su questo, ma vedete com'è profonda
nel Corano, e quindi nella mentalità collettiva del mondo islamico in molti momenti, l'idea
che è uno scandalo il fatto che in certe zone, in certe città, in certe regioni, prima
trionfava la vera fede, e poi sono arrivati i miscredenti. Questo ci aiuta a capire molte
cose, secondo me.
Però non li combattete presso il Tempio Sacro, a meno che essi non vi attacchino in quello,
e se essi vi attaccheranno, uccideteli. Tale è la ricompensa dei miscredenti. Se però
essi desistono, certamente Dio è indulgente e compassionevole. Combatteteli finché non
vi sia più discordia civile, e sia la religione solo quella di Dio. Se però essi desistono,
allora non vi siano più ostilità, se non contro gli iniqui. Ecco, qui c'è tutta la contraddittorietà,
mi permetto di chiamarla così, feconda sotto certi aspetti, spesso, ma comunque anche inquietante,
della concezione coranica della guerra santa, dove si insiste molto fortemente che la guerra
deve essere fatta innanzitutto contro chi ci aggredisce, però poi la sola esistenza
di gente che nega Dio è sentita come un'aggressione. E allora la gente che nega Dio deve essere combattuta
fino a quando non potrà più nuocere. Non poter più nuocere vuol dire che si sottomettono.
Qui c'è la base, perché dicevo feconda, un aspetto positivo di tutto questo, è che nei
grandi imperi islamici del passato esisteva, come sappiamo, non una tolleranza, la parola era
sbagliata. Ma i cristiani e gli ebrei ci potevano vivere, purché riconoscessero l'autorità
superiore delle autorità islamiche, pagassero delle tasse speciali e così via. Perché il
Corano lo dice espressamente, se depongono le armi e si sottomettono, possono continuare
a vivere presso di voi. Ovviamente però in una posizione subalterna. Nel Corano c'è
addirittura una sura, un passo, in cui si dice, ma le indicazioni sulla guerra santa
però sono un po' confuse, perché non ce n'è una chiara? 47, 22, arrivo eh. Dicono
quelli che credono, perché non è stata fatta scendere una sura che ordini la guerra? Ma
se fosse stata fatta scendere una sura precisa e fosse stata comandata in essa la guerra?
E poi preferisco parafrasare anziché tradurla perché è particolarmente complicata la frase
dopo, ma sembra che il senso sia che insomma ci sono molti troppo deboli per combattere
davvero e Dio non voleva metterli così in difficoltà ordinandola la guerra. Perciò
non l'ha ordinata, sono le autorità terrene che possono ordinarla e i fedeli devono sapersi
orientare a seconda del caso. Quindi il Corano stesso riconosce che la questione della guerra
santa è una questione complicata, ambigua, che non si è voluta dichiarare in modo formale.
Ma c'è ancora un momento, e il più sorprendente secondo me, in cui si parla di queste cose.
Non sono molti, il Corano è un grosso libro come vedete, ma non sono molti i brani in cui
si parla di guerra santa, anche se avete visto che quelli in cui se ne parla, ne parlano
e affrontano il problema, prendono il toro per le corne, insomma. Ecco, il passo sorprendente
è questo. Combattete nella via di Dio e sappiate che Dio sente e sa tutto. Dopodiché, come spesso
accade, Dio, o Maometto che trascrive, spiega il concetto facendo dei riferimenti a ciò che già è
conosciuto alle precedenti rivelazioni. Non vedesti l'assemblea dei figli di Israele dopo
la morte di Mosè, quando dissero ad un loro profeta, dacci un re e noi combatteremo nella
via di Dio? Disse allora il profeta, ma se vi sarà prescritto di combattere, certamente
combatterete. E quelli risposero, ma come potremmo non combattere nella via di Dio, visto che siamo
scacciati dalle nostre case e dai nostri figli? E però, quando fu loro prescritto di combattere,
essi volsero le spalle, tranne pochi di loro. Però Dio conosce gli iniqui. E continua raccontando
che effettivamente il profeta diede agli ebrei un re, Saul, e Saul li portò in guerra, e fecero
la guerra contro i loro nemici, i filistei, e Davide uccise Golia, e così via. Ecco.
In altre parole, Maometto sta facendo riferimento a un passo biblico molto preciso. Sta facendo
riferimento al secondo libro di Samuele, in cui si racconta esattamente questo, anche
se con sfumature che nel Corano non vengono fuori. Nel secondo libro di Samuele si racconta
che dopo che gli ebrei erano stati governati da Samuele, che però non aveva voluto farsi
re, ora che Samuele si avvicina alla morte e i suoi figli non sono in grado di assumere
la successione, gli ebrei chiedono a Samuele di disegnare un re. E Samuele non vuole. E
dite, ma lo sapete cosa vuol dire avere un re? Prenderai i vostri figli per condurli
in guerra, prenderai i vostri buoi, vi farà pagare le tasse, eccetera. E gli ebrei dicono,
no, noi vogliamo essere un popolo come tutti gli altri. Com'è che dicono? Avremo un re
che ci governerà, che uscirà alla testa dei nostri soldati e combatterà le nostre
battaglie. Samuele va da Dio e gli dice, ma guarda che questi vogliono un re, e Dio
gli dice, vabbè, se proprio lo vogliono, accontentali. E Samuele designa Saul. Ora, qual
è il punto? Che questo brano nel libro di Samuele è ambiguo, perché non è chiaro
che avere un re e seguirlo in guerra sia una bella cosa. Anzi, sembrerebbe che Samuele
la pensi diversamente, li sconsiglia. Però poi è anche vero che quando questo re arriva,
ed è un re infatti che traligna, Saul, però dopo di lui ci sarà Davide, ci saranno
i re di Israele, e gli ebrei combatteranno tutta una serie di guerre che la Bibbia presenta
come guerre sacrosante e vittoriose. Ecco, come vi dicevo, Maometto conosce bene la tradizione
ebraica e cristiana quando ha le sue rivelazioni e detta le sue idee, e riprende largamente le
cose che gli servono. Qui riprende semplificando un po'. Il fatto che nel libro di Samuele
questa guerra non sia così chiaro se è giusta o no, qui cade. Per Maometto combattere i nemici
di Dio è giusto, e Dio l'ha già detto tante volte, l'ha detto ai profeti degli ebrei,
e adesso lo sta ridicendo a Maometto. Ecco, credo che ce ne sia abbastanza per riflettere
insomma sulla complessità di queste fedi religiose che si sono intrecciate fra loro, e su come sia
complesso poi il problema di quanto i credenti debbano seguire i precetti, aggiungerei un'ultima
cosa appunto da storico. Da storici noi ci rendiamo conto che i testi sacri sono sempre
quelli, ma le diverse epoche li interpretano ciascuna a suo modo. Come vi dicevo, nel mondo
islamico di Guerra Santa si era parlato pochissimo, nel nono, decimo, undicesimo secolo, ma appena
arrivano i crociati, già durante la prima crociata, alla prima battaglia persa dai musulmani
in cui molti cadono, molti fuggono, i crociati li inseguono, e i primi cronisti arabi che raccontano
questa vicenda già scrivono, solo un gruppo di Mujahidin tenne fermo, Mujahidin cioè i combattenti
della Guerra Santa naturalmente, Mujahidin tra l'altro, scusate il dettaglio, viene direttamente
da Jihad, la radice di Jihad con il prefisso Mu che indica le persone che fanno qualcosa
e quindi i Mujahidin sono quelli che fanno il Jihad. Solo un gruppo di Mujahidin tenne
fermo e si battè per acquistare merito presso Dio e cercare il martirio. I franchi ne uccisono
la migliaia e così via. La reazione è immediata. Io non so se questo ci possa aiutare a capire
come mai queste persone che in fondo alla fine ragionavano in modo così simile, che adoravano
lo stesso Dio, anche se con regole diverse, e che avevano atteggiamenti mentali così simili,
non so se questo ci aiuta a capire come mai le loro guerre erano così feroci. Lo erano.
Una delle cose che colpiscono di più nei racconti delle prime crociate è vedere con
quanta allegria i cronisti cristiani raccontano dei crociati che tornano vittoriosi con le
teste dei turchi appese alle selle, oppure issate sulle picche, ma d'altra parte i cronisti
arabi e entusiasti raccontano di come i loro guerrieri tornano indietro con le teste dei
cristiani appese alle selle. Qualche storico che ha studiato lungo le crociate ha finito
per dire che l'argomento è un po' desolante e che non è una delle pagine più entusiasmanti
della storia umana. Le crociate sono però anche il momento in cui, appunto, queste civiltà
diverse, anche se così legate senza saperlo, neanche loro lo sospettavano, quanto erano
vicini e quanto erano legati, queste civiltà diverse si incontrano e si descrivono a vicenda.
E dunque domani torneremo non più ad analizzare ma a raccontare e racconteremo come chi non veniva
dall'Occidente, chi viveva fuori a Bisanzio o nel mondo islamico, vedeva i nostri antenati
partiti con tutto questo bagaglio di idee che abbiamo cercato di evocare. Grazie.